howard hamlin started off as the classic
good-looking
uptight boss who wasn't so good looking
under the hood
though we all loved to hate on howard's
douchey personality
it was quickly revealed soon after that
howard wasn't a true douche
but chuck chuck howard and howard's
father
had built hhm from the ground up into a
well-respected regional firm
and chuck definitely did not want
slipping jimmy
to ruin this elite reputation but how
much was this prestigious firm of
hhm even worth in the first place
well starting off we'll look at
estimating their revenue
to estimate the size of the law firm
itself jimmy reveals that his 20
portion of the common fund is worth
about 1.16 million dollars
this means that the total expected
revenue from the case is 5.8 million
dollars
however this is if jimmy had succeeded
in closing the case early like he
originally wanted to do
hhm as well as davis and main however
were pushing back the settlement of the
case as they were hoping to get much
more
so given that jimmy doesn't entirely go
through with this original plan to cash
out of the case
it's likely that the law firms were able
to gather more evidence and raise the
stakes
we'll say that they were able to get it
up to a 10 million cash out
moving on to how much of this a law firm
actually gets
from jimmy explaining the cash-out
situation to the people at saint piper
we know that the law firms get a bigger
portion of the pot than the victims
themselves
now this isn't necessarily because the
law firms are greedy like jimmy portrays
but simply because running a law firm is
quite expensive
furthermore class action lawsuits take
years
so those funds have to be profitable for
the firms over
many years assuming that the firms get
of the fund and the sandpiper residents
get 30 the two law firms would end up
with 5 million
in revenue hhm was the original and the
main firm working on the case
so it's likely that they get the
majority of the revenue
with a 60 40 split hhm would pull in a
total of 3 million
from the sandpiper case by the end of
season 5 of better call saul
the case has been dragging on for two
years we'll likely see the end of the
case in season six
so that's a three year long case coming
out to one million dollars in revenue
per year for hhm
from sandpiper the next step would be to
estimate how many lawyers are
actually working on the case to estimate
the firm's revenue per lawyer
from this shot it seems like up to 7
lawyers from hhm
could be working on the case but the
thing is
the show's writers likely didn't look
too deeply into such logistics
and simply wanted a filled discussion
room so
that isn't a very accurate
representation of how many lawyers were
actually working on the case from davis
and main side
we have jimmy and aaron but that's
likely it
anymore wouldn't make economical sense
considering that davis and maine are
doing about 40
of the work hhm likely has about three
lawyers working on the sandpiper case
this would make sense because the median
salary for a class action lawyer
is 117 000 per year
this means that the lawyers would cost
hhm about 350 000
per year or about a third of the revenue
which is the industry standard
as for how much hhm profits at the end
of the day
this comes down to how much the overhead
is other than their attorneys
this would include things like the
building expenses court fees
filing fees paralegals and of course the
people working in dock review
generally this cost law firms between 20
and 33 percent
as the average profit margin for law
firms range between 35 percent
and 45 percent with the best pushing
into the 50s
so we'll give hhm a healthy profit
margin of 40
that leaves just one thing left on the
table which is jimmy's fees
hhm seems to be a pretty reputable law
firm in the area
and so they definitely don't rely on
just referrals to run the firm
the main reason they took on the
sandpiper case and our finals paying
jimmy 20
is not because it's a lucrative case per
se but because it's a class action
lawsuit
which will significantly bolster their
reputation so
for the vast majority of cases they
won't have to deal with this 20 percent
now that 20 wouldn't just be pocketed by
hhm otherwise
but it would give them the ability to
hire more lawyers and spend more time on
the case
to get it done faster and more
efficiently so
though their revenue from the sandpiper
case is 1 million dollars per year
they would generally put in 20 higher
than that at 1.2 million
with all of this information we can set
up the basic financial metrics of the
company
hhm pulls in about 400 000 per lawyer
per year in revenue of which they profit
about 40 percent
so to estimate their total revenue and
profit
we just have to figure out how many
lures hhm is likely to have
the largest law firms in the world
actually have thousands of lawyers
but we know that hhm is just a mid-sized
regional firm
and ohio state university suggests that
mid-sized firms
generally have 10 to 50 attorneys hhm
is bigger than davis and maine but
smaller than schweicart and coakley
considering that those are also
mid-sized firms we'll put hhm
right in the middle with 30 attorneys
with the 400 thousand dollars in revenue
per attorney per year
hhm would be pulling in about 12 million
in revenue per year
of which 4.8 million dollars would be
profit
as for how much chuck and howard get
from this we can estimate this
based on their equity stakes on the
stock market
companies are generally worth 10 to 20
times their yearly profit
but since this is a law firm and tusk
doesn't have tech company level growth
potential
we'll give them a modest p e ratio or
price to earnings ratio
of 10. with 4.8 million dollars in
profit per year
hhm is worth about 50 million dollars
when howard buys out chuck sharer we
know that he gives chuck three million
dollars
which is the first of three payments
assuming that all the payments are equal
chuck's equity in the company is nine
million dollars or about 20
of the company as howard owns his own
share as well as his father's share
he would have about 40 equity in the
company or 18 million dollars worth
this makes sense as this leaves 40 to be
owned by junior
and senior partners of the firm if 10 to
15 of the 30 attorneys were partners
they could each get assault one to three
percent of the firm
while that doesn't sound like a lot
that's a solid extra 50 to 150 000
a year on top of their base salaries
pushing them well into the two hundreds
and even three hundreds
and that doesn't even take into account
the market value of your equity stake
so definitely a worthwhile job for most
people
anyways moving back to chuck and howard
with respect to 20 and 40
stakes in hhm they would get 960 000
per year and 1.92 million dollars per
year
in other words chalk is worth about 10
million dollars
and makes about a million dollars a year
while howard is worth about 20 million
and makes 2 million a year and that's
just their net worth and income from hhm
both of them could have easily invested
their incomes and grown tens of millions
of net worth outside of hhm ironically
these actors are worth about the same in
real life
looks like they were the perfect
selections for the roles but that's just
what i think
how much do you guys think hhm is worth
make sure to comment that down below
also drop a like if you guys like the
depth of this analysis
and consider subscribing to see more
questions largely answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one
[Music]
you